All right, what's up guys? In this video
I'm going to go over how I like to
personally go about trading failed
auctions, right? So,
firstly, this is on a TPO chart. So, you
can apply the same idea to a volume
profile, to a VWAP, really any level. In
this case, given the way I like to trade
is based off of value. A lot of the time
that's kind of the the core for how I've
built up my framework and my style of
trading. So, I like to trade off of
value. So, if you're not familiar with
what TPO is, essentially is the same
thing as a volume profile in the sense
that it's measuring time at price as as
as sorry, instead of volume.
Uh it's the same in the fact that it has
a distribution, right? It has a value
low, value high, point of control. Uh
so, it's the same thing, right? So, you
can apply the kind of same idea of
auction market theory and and the kind
of trades you can take off of that as
you would to a volume profile. So, if
you're within value, this will be
resistance, this will be support. If
you're outside of value, value area low
is resistance.
Uh value area high is support, right?
So, exactly the same thing in that
sense. Um
Right. So, a failed auction, right? If
you're not familiar with what a failed
auction is, I'll put it in really kind
of simple terms here, right? So, against
value here, right? Just for simplicity's
sake, if we're within value here, right?
Price is doing this.
If we break down from value, right? This
is now resistance going forward.
This is the market attempting to auction
lower or attempting to trade lower. If
it fails to lead to a trend and we start
to kind of range here or balance, right?
That's kind of indicative of of
weakness, right? It's definitely not
strength because we haven't traded
lower. And in that case, if it resolves
by
trading back into value again, that
would be a failure or failed auction
below value. In that case, you're no
longer bearish against this profile, you
would be bullish against the profile.
Right?
So, how could you go about trading this,
right? So, um do you want to buy the low
down here? Probably not, right? Because
we just broke down from this profile. It
doesn't make a lot of sense to to be
bullish or trying to catch a bottom
when you know context is that we just
shifted bearish against this profile.
If you're a bit confused here as to why
there's no candles,
historically on a TPO chart there is no
candles, but what you can do is expand
the profile which I'll show you that now
quickly. Firstly,
this is what you'd call a 5-day
composite. So these are all daily
profiles. Of course the same thing can
apply to weekly, can apply to session,
can apply to monthly. Doesn't matter how
big the profile is, the same principles
can apply.
So a composite is when value areas
overlap between profiles. So essentially
this is this is five daily profiles in a
row that overlap. Meaning that you can
merge these.
I remember it's sorry it's 4-day profile
I believe. So 4-day profile, 4-day
composite. So you can merge them and you
get a larger profile to work with. So
I'm just going to mark that off here
quickly with a box.
So we can work with that going forward.
So let's just draw this across like that
just for reference.
And with that like I said there's no
candles here, but what you can do with
TPO is that you can expand the profile.
Right? And then you can see how that
profile actually came to be from
beginning of the day or beginning of the
session to the end of the session. So
you can see that we open within value
right near value high, which is this
green dot. We retested value high here.
So again this is resistance till it's
not. This is support till it's not.
Right? So if you longed here that's not
a totally incorrect trade. Right? Of
course you can look at order flow and
other things.
Um
but given we're within value that's
this would be resistance, this would be
support. Right? Until we break through.
So you can see that
you know, we we retested it, we tested
it one more time. Make sure there's
buyers here. They get flushed which
leads to this kind of aggressive move
down.
Okay? And then from there
we retested value area low as resistance
given that we're now outside of value
and this should lead
to lower. Right? Like I said if it's
trying to auction lower and it doesn't
right? Then something has changed. So
this should lead to a trend, and if it
doesn't, then, you know, it starts to
round off, then that may lead to a
failed auction and reversion back within
value. So,
what I'll do here now is expand the
following day, and we'll see what
happened, and we'll break this down. So,
instead of trying to long the bottom
after we just broke down from this
value, which again doesn't make sense,
right? Why would you want to do that? Of
course, other other contexts and other
levels can be taken into account, but
just with what we're working with here,
just surface up, let's just say,
probably not a long you'd want to take,
right? So, we break down, we retest it,
try to trade lower. So, if you shorted
this, that would be a good short. I did
I did short this myself, too. Um
right, we trade into this low, we put a
bottom in around here. We come up and
start retesting. So, we're just putting
in these kind of weaker, poor highs
here.
There's a short squeeze above these
highs. So, any early sellers here got
taken out.
We try and trade lower one more time.
It, you know, retests the prior day
value low.
Excuse me, and that's where the bottom
is put in here, right? And then, if you
go and look, we spent multiple hours or
you know, a day, day and a half,
whatever this was, below value area low,
and this should have led to a trend, but
it didn't.
Right? So, that's just as important as
it actually, you know, the fact that it
didn't lead to a trend is just as
important as it leading to a trend,
right? In regards to kind of what's
going on with the market. So,
if you go and look what happened, right,
we retested it here as support,
or sorry, resistance, try to trade
lower, we didn't,
right? We then traded up,
and it became support again, and then we
get the move
back to value area high,
if I expand this profile here,
right?
Let's remove these, right? Retest it,
move up to value high.
And then, I didn't lock this box, but
either way,
right?
And then, same thing, you know, can be
said about the upside, right? So, again,
this would be a larger failed auction
over the weekend. So, we we trade up, we
retest it here, even here in a lower
time frame, you can argue, which was
good, right? We retested it and and it
did trend for a bit. So, this would be
another good long to take, which I
believe I also took. Uh and then over
the weekend, which of course, you it's
going to result in less volume anyways,
because it's the weekend uh on BTC. Um
we built up more days of balance here,
and this actually became a 3-day
composite, but my point is
again, lots of lots of time and lots of
volume, a lot of many multiple days
spent above this level, but it didn't
amount to trading higher. Right? So, if
it does fail here, right? This is
support, this is support, this is
support, this is support. As soon as you
lose this support,
same with here, any buyers that are
positioned here, anywhere within this
region, likely, you know,
as we trade lower, they're going to be
forced to puke their positions, so
you're going to see an accelerated move
back through value, right? So, value
area high, which was support, will be
lost, it'll become resistance, right?
And then your next target is going to be
value low, point of control, so on and
so forth.
Right? So, if we go ahead and expand
this,
again, this should have led to a trend,
it did not. So, this is a failed auction
above value area high, and you see
acceptance back within the profile. So,
if we expand this one, same thing can be
said here. On lower time frames, you
know, if you're reading order flow,
which I was for this short, I also took
this one.
Um
you could see, not only do you know
there's absolutely going to be buyers
positioned here over the weekend, but
even shorter time frame around this kind
of cluster here.
Um when you look at a TPO chart, you you
can you're Sorry, you're looking at the
30-minute time frame, so I can't get
very granular here and show you what
happened within these bars.
Um so, I can't show you, but
uh nonetheless,
there was buyers, especially positioned
around here. So, any any late buyers
here, as we bounce it kind of one more
time, when we start to trade lower, and
they're forced to unwind, you're going
to see an accelerated move. So, we
didn't get a larger retest, but again,
you just kind of have to go with
strength at that point. And, you know,
from there
there's your destination. We got another
bounce back up, and then we traded
lower.
Um and then, you know, the same things
you know, repeated itself
uh right here, right? So,
uh a bit messier this time, but again,
the exact same thing happened this day,
and then the following day repeated
itself as we did in the prior day,
right? So, this was Tuesday, I believe.
Um this was Monday into Tuesday, so very
similar interactions here.
So, let me just
expand this profile, right? So, the same
thing happened. So, we again
we had a failed auction below, we trade
back in.
Let me fix this marker.
Right? Failed auction below, we trade
back in value, trade up, attempt to
hold,
cap, fail, right?
Failed auction above value high, trade
back into value, okay? We end up
breaking through.
Now, we're spending time below here
again. Sellers are getting absorbed down
here,
right? And the same thing happens. Being
that we broke down from value, this is
resistance now.
Uh and it was support within value,
right? So, given that we failed down
here once more, it's another failed
auction below the same value. Of course,
this box is moving on me, but my point
still stands.
And then, we get a move back into value,
right? And that's the long you want to
take.
And then,
like I said, it it it's it's very
repeatable. So, it's a it's a very good
setup to take. It's it's a it's a failed
shift, and then you take the the
preceding kind of shift, right? So, very
powerful stuff.
Um especially when you can take this and
put it into proper context and kind of
the way that I like to frame it and use,
you know, multiple different profiles at
once, multiple different VWAPs, the way
that we kind of do it within within the
Discord.
Um you can really frame things together
really, really well.
Uh and then, this you know, this is an
example of what a proper shift should
look like, right? So, if you look at the
following day here,
right?
Um well, we we looked at proper ones
here, but nonetheless, you know, this is
a failure below value, okay? This is
This is a failed to break down from
value.
All right?
This is a successful trade back inside.
This would be a successful breakout of
that level, right? And then we traded
up.
Right?
That would be a good example of that.
Which I also took this one.
Right? And then I believe even today or
yesterday, let's just expand this one.
Um a bit shorter term here, but I even
took this one as a scalp today. Um a bit
harder to see and be more granular here,
but nonetheless we built that balance
here.
Okay?
We traded up, and then you can see we
retested it right here. Right? And then
And then we ended up sweeping the high.
But there was a scalp there today, too,
which I also took and and sent to the
Discord. So, nonetheless, it's it's very
powerful in that sense.
Right? So,
should zoom out one more time, reset
these.
Where is this? Collapse.
So, like I said, this can be applied to
TPO, it can be applied to VWAP, it can
be applied to really any level. Of
course, the way I trade is is based off
of of multiple kind of forms of value in
that sense.
So, that's how I like to do it, but like
I said, you know, being that you know,
trading down from value should lead to
to a trend or or going imbalanced.
Right? This is a balanced market. This
would be imbalanced, right? So, when we
traded up here, that was going
imbalanced, right? And then this would
be balanced market. So,
um
yeah, guys, really really good setup.
Something you should definitely give a
shot in your trading.
And uh yeah, wishing you that everybody
the best in the market. Cheers.